le niger face à son destin
après deux mandats du président sortant
mamadou issoufou le pays peut être gay à
la première transition démocratique de
son histoire
ce second tour verra s'opposer le
candidat du parti au pouvoir mohamed
bazoum arrivé en tête avec 39% des voix
à mamane ousmane président du niger de
1993 à 1996 dans ce territoire enclavé
au coeur du sahel qui a subi de nombreux
coups d'état
l'espoir est immense près de deux mois
après le premier tour
la commission électorale du pays se veut
confiante sur la bonne organisation du
scrutin dans le ventre et les autorités
or au niveau et les autorités rossé de
la ceni ont pris toutes les dispositions
je dis bien toutes les dispositions pour
que tous ces donneurs normalement en
tout cas dans l'intérêt de tous une
élection qui se déroule sous haute
tension
le pays est en proie depuis plusieurs
années à des attaques de groupes
djihadistes affiliés à des ch et à boko
haram
des milliers de soldats ont été déployés
pour sécuriser le scrutin
des précautions qui n'empêche pas
l'inquiétude d'une partie de la
population au coloriste
c'est ça mais pour les grands problèmes
vraiment l'insécurité
nous ce qu'on attend des élections c'est
qui ça se passe d'abord dans la plus
grande transparence avec m
pour ac provençal des électeurs et tout
le monde participe
il est massif en votes qui se déroulera
sous la supervision de dizaines
d'observateurs de la communauté
économique d'afrique de l'ouest
en cas de succès de l'élection est
acceptation du résultat par l'opposition
le défi du futur président sera immense
objectif principal accélérer le
développement du pays
classé dernier au monde sur l' indice de
développement humain établi par le
programme des nations unies pour le
développement